a cuboid is simply a box like this it is
three-dimensional as it does not occupy
a part of just one plane three things
define a cuboid length its breadth and
its height this is a cuboid what will be
its surface area as the name suggests it
will be the total area of all its
surfaces a cuboid has six surfaces in
all one at the front and one at the back
their areas will be equal as it has a
uniform cross section area of each will
be L times H and the total area of both
together will be 2l H similarly the sum
of the areas of the faces at the top and
bottom together will be 2 lb and the sum
of the areas of the faces on the right
and left will be 2 B H that's the total
surface area of a cuboid taking the
factor 2 common we can write it as twice
L h plus lb plus BH what is its lateral
surface area there the word lateral
simply means side this is the sum of the
areas of the faces on the side not the
faces at the top or the bottom so it
will just be twice L H plus BH we
ignored 2 lb as they are the areas of
the top and bottom surfaces so these are
the two types of surface areas we had to
understand the last concept is that of
its volume the volume of a cuboid is
simply the product of its length its
breadth and its height lb h to be more
specific it is the area of its base
times its height knowing stuff about
cuboids also helps us understand its
special case the case of a cube it looks
similar to a cuboid it has length
breadth and height with the only
difference being that all three are
well let's say each is equal to s units
think about it if each of the sides are
equal then each face will be a square
the area of each face will be s squared
as there are six faces the total surface
area will be six s squared what will be
the lateral surface area and the volume
then as it has four faces on the side
its lateral surface area will be four s
squared as lb and H are all equal to s
the volume of a cube will be site cubed
in the next session we will look at the
volume and surface area of a cylinder
you